people of the internet retrorec into her
here welcome back
to another episode of harry potter and
the philosopher's stoner harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone depending on
where you live we're gonna go ahead and
jump
right back in here so in part one we
left off
we had just absolutely destroyed
malfoy i mean absolutely destroyed
malfoy
as we tried to get neville's remember
all back and of course we succeeded
now we are getting ready to i believe
head to hagrid's hut you see we're
playing this off an ssd
the the loading screens are so fast it
barely gives me any time to read
anything so
we're gonna jump right back in here if
we're meeting for the first time guys
i'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
little pendo there we post videos every
week here
on youtube and if you guys enjoy this
video today or any of my videos
make sure to give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button before you go it really does help
out the channel
now i don't remember any of this in
harry potter let me tell you okay so we
got a couple things going on here
we got those plants up there which we
can use a spell on and we've got kind of
like this little hidden spot back here
so i think first i'd like to check this
out
[Music]
cast a little aloha more there may be a
wizard card no a single
birdie bot bean really like really
a single beam okay that's how we're
gonna do it tonight all right
[Music]
so a lot of times when i've played games
like this i'm usually
i'm streaming it's actually my first
ever just
let's play so this is not streamed live
uh you guys can follow me over on twitch
though i'm still trying to figure out
exactly oh goodness
cornish pixie right up in my face man i
was not expecting that
i'm still trying to figure out like that
right balance between
streaming and youtube and i posted a
poll
on youtube that if you haven't voted in
it yet feel free but i'm just wondering
do you guys prefer
videos that are more like this for let's
plays where i am i am
literally just talking to you guys the
youtube audience there's no chat here
there's no
no kind of unknown people that you can't
see
that would be part of a live
a little stream there or something aloha
was a little a little late on alamora
but
okay we got more birdy bop beans you
guys know how i feel about the beans i'd
much rather see a wizard card but hey
dude this why is this pixie all over me
i guess we need some pesky pixie pester
no me up in here don't we
oh wait that wasn't a real spell like
like it hits him but it just seems to
to agitate him even more all right so
the point of this whole area i guess was
just to find some more beans
all right okay a little uh
a little hidden spot in the wall i guess
that's it then all right
so we're gonna head on back okay we
can't jump on that rock
i guess are you serious are you serious
come on harry
i did not think that little flame that
he left behind would hurt me
you guys are like really retro you you
didn't think the flame would hurt you
you know it's like like a little flame
on the ground you just run through it
fast enough you should be fine right
apparently not we need to hop over
instead
oh wait i just heard a chocolate frog
though
sounds like he's in that direction yeah
i guess harry doesn't know aguamenti yet
so we can't put out the fire
dude it sounds like he's like behind
that wall somewhere i guess i can't get
to him
all right so can we hop on top of these
no we cannot
all right guess we gotta go around here
really surely we can do this
flip endo all right nicely done harry
okay can we hop up here now
there we go there we go yeah but most
people that have voted in the polls so
far
uh it seemed to be that most people
didn't seem to mind if i posted a let's
play
that had also been live streamed on
twitch as well
i've been watching a lot more let's
plays recently just because
i really want to do more of them on the
channel i mean
gaming is at the heart of what i do and
now since we've got
[Music]
apparently a really long wait before
hogwarts legacy
it's like well we're gonna need some
some fresh content here on the channel
so how about
how about some more let's plays and i've
been watching a lot of them
and it seems like they at least the ones
i've been watching lately
they i think that they're just streaming
like straight
to youtube and i mean i said streaming
what i meant was just
just posting it straight to youtube like
there's no twitch stream
along with it now then there are plenty
of others who do have have the twitch
stream that
it's clear that it's a twitch stream and
they've just you know pulled from there
but i'm going to try out both man see
how it feels there's just something
about like
i kind of like this vibe of knowing that
i'm talking directly to you guys the
youtube audience
i'm still going to keep streaming i mean
i'm not i'm not going to totally abandon
streaming but just trying to figure out
how it works out into the schedule here
all right i can't believe i just went
all the way back down for those birdie
bop beans but
you got to do what you got to do there
you go
nice job harry all right these little uh
i think these are fire salamanders if i
remember correctly
oh come on what the fupindo's just not
ready yet oh it actually
actually hit that guy instead okay
there's a chocolate frog let's grab
that get our health up and then we're
gonna head over here
and do this little bit watch how fast
this saves you ready for it
you blink you'll miss it somebody see if
you could screen cap that
see how good you are see how good you
try and screencap that
that single frame where it popped up
okay i don't like that these cornish
pixies are
rushing me here
okay it actually does stun them i guess
they run no no no i don't like this
[Music]
and that looks like just a let's see if
we can take a peek down there
just an endless pit of despair oh my
goodness we're gonna die to cornish
pixies right here
come on be a chocolate frog dude you
need a chocolate frog in a worse way
okay more beans i i don't understand
goodness okay there's a chuckle look at
this
they're chasing me all right
and now the fire salamander in the back
all right two flapindos back to back
grab the chocolate frog and we are out
of here dude i do not want any
part of those cornish pixies
cornish pixies most dominant enemy and
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
do you imagine
surely we're going to encounter some uh
tougher enemies later on we'll see
i got quite a bit of platforming going
on here i don't know how i feel about
this
these like tank controls make it make it
pretty hard to
maneuver harry around here all right
nothing extra over
there at least it doesn't seem like it
nicely done and another load or another
save i'm sorry not load
on you on you
and it reveals a flupido switch
yeah this is not i don't remember this
from the books do you guys
i is this really what the trio had to go
through every time they wanted to
to make make a trip to hagrid's hut
oh wait a second should i have
nah i bet we're gonna i bet we're gonna
need to do that later
venomous tentacula coming out
incendial back to back
there we go
and by get rid of i mean just
temporarily stunned
okay make sure i'm not missing anything
up there all right
all right i do not like the looks of
this area right here we've got the two
venomous tentaculars
and some fire crabs or the fire are they
fire crabs or fire salamanders
let me know in the comments guys i'm
sure they said it at some point in this
game
see the completeness in me like clearly
i didn't need to destroy all of them
to get to this chest or even to get to
this little uh
secret spot over here on the left but
i'm just a completionist
i gotta do it i gotta do it
all right now where this is going to
lead
remains to be seen hopefully not just to
another
chest of beans oh here we go here it is
here's the here's the chest of beans i
guarantee
what
[Music]
all right yep there's our beans
i wonder if this is the inferior cave
from blood prince how crazy would it be
if you like look down in the pool
i don't even think we knew about
inferior at this point i don't even know
if jk rowling knew about inferior at
this point
when this game was made actually by the
time this game was made she probably did
but when this book was written i highly
doubt
anyone else knew of inferior except
maybe joe
all right wizard card here
as always you guys know we like to check
the date on these guys to see
if it's possible that we could see them
in hogwarts like i said wow it just got
really quiet that was that was weird
taking out the waterfall was it this guy
edelberg waffling now we got him last
time i think it was this gentleman
right here bowman wright 1492-1560
famous for developing the golden
snitch bowman right there he is picture
with a little snitch right there
nicely done bowman nicely done all right
so let's back out
looks like we are catching slytherin
right here there at 284 gryffindor 255
224 for ravenclaw and hufflepuff come on
hufflepuffs you guys are better than
this i don't care what anybody says
132 you're better than this all right is
that it right here
if you really think about it like in the
harry potter books
shouldn't hufflepuff be the most likely
group to dominate
i mean i know the ravenclaws are gonna
do really well in class
but hufflepuffs are just nice to
everybody right
maybe being nice doesn't pay maybe
maybe it doesn't pay off but you would
think they would be like so generous to
teachers and everything
i guess that's they're just too nice
they don't want to compete in uh
in sports or anything i'm kidding i'm
kidding guys i love hufflepuffs
my wife is totally a hufflepuff she is
incredibly
loyal dedicated to her family
uh just a hufflepuff through and through
at first she got all mad at me like when
i was like you're totally hufflepuff
and she took the quiz on jk on a
pottermore yeah it confirmed
it confirmed she was a hufflepuff
a lot of people in the comments have
been asking me which house am i in
i think i've mentioned it a couple times
but i know not everybody sees every
single video
uh i am a gryffindor
gryffindor with with ravenclaw probably
a close second
although i've there have been some tests
that i've taken in the past where i've
gotten ravenclaw i'll be honest with you
i've never felt like i was
smart enough for ravenclaw i did do well
in school growing up
in college and everything but i don't
know it just didn't
i just i i i feel i feel more closely
aligned to gryffindor
and most of the tests i've taken do
including the pottermore one
there's actually a test online you can
find where it actually incorporates all
of the pottermore questions
not just a couple of them collect the
fire scenes okay over here
come along then i have something to show
you oh
what do you got is it the dragon by the
way congratulations on making the
quidditch team
word travels fast drone hogwarts thank
you hagrid
yeah it's like all this in my first day
apparently there's no day night cycle in
this game i'm going to be home harry
hey small but still room oh there it is
the dragon
now i can show you what i wanted to talk
to you about
there it is norbert it's a dragon's egg
harry
but it's our secret mind yeah the egg is
at a very delicate stage
i can't leave it here alone but i need
some fire seeds to give it that last
burst of heat to make it hatch
oh all right i can help with that catch
me some fire seeds
i grow them in caves out in the garden
out in mega
i need you to collect as many fire seeds
as you can find
i got you covered they're spitting fire
and the seeds are hot
let them cool down for you pick them up
off you go then
let them cool down before you pick them
up okay that's actually a game mechanic
i think i need to remember that
that's important but yeah there's
there's a test out there that
incorporates all of the pottermore
questions
and i've taken that one multiple times
and i've gotten gryffindor every time
i i might actually do that on a that
might be a fun video sorting retro
so you guys can see how i answer the
questions all right
i totally know that he wants me to go
collect the seeds
out back in the garden but i kind of
just want to explore around is there
anything we can
is there anything else we can do here in
this area
okay i don't think it'll let us go back
that way
[Music]
got the pigs over here hello pigs any
hippogrips
wow those are some really big pigs
oh my goodness these are like enchanted
pigs have to be
and they do not look happy that i'm
coming so close okay fine i'll back off
and then a lone goat over here i think
it's a goat right yeah
better make sure aberforth stays away
right
am i right all right let's head this way
i believe this is the way to the fire
seeds
i don't even remember how many he said
to collect oh my goodness those cornish
pixies again
i feel like oh okay let's do flopindo
like it stuns him and keeps it from
hitting me but then it doesn't last
forever they just keep coming back for
more
cornish pixies
oh no
[Applause]
yeah i just didn't want to take the time
to dispel
check this area over here come on
chocolate frog
chocolate frog i don't think chocolate
frogs can even are you serious
us a single bean that's just cruel man
that's just cool but they have chests
with a lone
birdie bop bean i actually don't know
how many more hits we can take by the
way guys
not too many and we've got some pixies
coming up
oh there's a frog right there
yes definitely in need of that chocolate
frog
oh i wonder if you can cast alohomora on
that over there
might be a hidden passage oh can he make
that
yes harry's got some hops
come on can he make that too nope denied
i didn't think so
but it was worth the shot right it was
worth a shot
okay so we're gonna have to back up and
jump harry nicely done
jump hurry my boy yes
secret passage alohomora alone
chest and what we got inside
wow wow i don't have my face came on but
if you guys could see my expression
right now
you could probably imagine it just just
a look of incredible disgust and
disappointment
it's not that i don't enjoy collecting
the beans i do
but i would much rather get the wizard
cards
all right where are those fire seasons
we have to go all the way through here
it's like another
saved game book
see if we do all this without stopping
oh
i did not think i had made i did not
think i made it on that last one
all right so we got more cornish pixies
ahead deadly deadliest enemy
in the game we've already established
up this okay
are you serious come on dude i need some
chocolate frogs like hiding out
maybe behind the secret passageway
what okay this is uh
go ahead and castle pindo over here
so i don't have to worry about
accidentally stepping in the flames
ah and this opens up the other side okay
more beans i feel like beans should
restore a tiny amount of health
not a lot like just a tiny tiny bit
and then the uh chocolate frogs should
restore
at least a lot more than they do because
i'm still
i mean i'm below half and i just grabbed
that chocolate frog i haven't gotten hit
since we grabbed that
[Music]
gosh if there's one thing they nailed in
this game it is the music right
first movie first game both
i mean just with incredible music
all right i hear another frog there he
is
let's go dude oh i did not mean to jump
i i actually i hit the right click
and apparently right click is also set
up to jump
oh goodness i almost jumped right into
the water there
that would not have been good all right
let's head on over here
dude that is a long jump
i feel like i need my broomstick come on
harry
yes all right i don't like the looks of
that
if this was dark souls something would
like push that down
start rolling at me i just got done
playing demon souls guys on ps5
incredible remake by the way but any of
you dark souls demon souls fan you know
what i'm talking about
okay another birdie bought bean and
another chocolate frog okay we are
almost back to max health here that is
great news
can we cast it again we can i didn't
know if we'd be able to completely
knock that one out of the way and i did
see that chest don't worry
i just want to double check try and
figure out which way is okay i think
i think this right here is the correct
path so let's go back
let's jump over here yeah it looks like
the only thing you can do here is open
up this chest
and more beans my goodness we've found a
lot of birdie belt beans tonight 232
right now as our total
[Music]
i'm surprised you can't castle pindo on
those barrels
and get even more birdie bob beans all
right nothing there
can i cast it again no okay nothing
there either
all right here we go that looks like one
of them that must be a fire seed plant
hagrid told me to stay away from the hot
seeds
all right do we have anything right
now that we can cast on them yes we do
okay now do i need to wait or cast
lapindo on them
okay now it looks like it's cooled off
perfect
all right that's three right there oh
and then
magically the gate opens all right i
think as let's say i think this is the
room with the cornish pixie
get off me bro
just got our health full pretty close to
full
i don't want a random cornish pixie
taking it away wait did that actually
get rid of him that time
chad i don't know what i was seeing
earlier
see i just said chat like i'm streaming
youtube whoever's watching this out
there
i feel like earlier that i hit flapindo
on them and they did not
just vanish like that all right another
save game book
maybe we just didn't get a direct hit on
them like we did right there
through the waterfall we go all right
there's another one
go ahead and explore a little bit while
we wait for those to cool off make sure
there's no secret passages back here
nothing over here
[Music]
all right and they are good to go now
should bring me up to six right here
let's see now we go back to the
waterfall
oh man i thought i messed that one up
okay there we go there we go
another chest waiting for us up here
oh wait can we not get there yet all
right remember that guys i bet it's
going to be
through that waterfall right there on
our right
yeah totally totally all right while you
cool off
i'm going to go aloha right here
and let's open up this chest more beans
fully expecting more beans
yep yep there we go
oh goodness
but he bolts every flavor beans i
actually haven't had any birdie bop
beans in
years i remember when they first came
out with them
we uh my family we bought some and then
they have them at the wizarding world
too but i i never got any when i was
there
but they one of them is sardine and
my grandpa apparently likes sardines of
course we were really
young kids at the time my sisters and i
were just like
freaking out as he's eating the sardine
birdie bop bean oh my gosh that is so
gross
and so they were like does it actually
taste like sardines and he said it did
he said it it totally
tasted like sardines so nice job
by the birdie bot folks of making the
sardines taste
uh like sardines all right that one's
good to go
i don't even remember how many he said
but we're up to 12 now
all right gonna jump up here follow the
arrow hagrid i appreciate
you uh putting the arrows up by the way
what is this
what in the world is that dude
what is this oh wait blasting it screwed
i'm getting out of here the blast if
that's a blast in its groot they
definitely look
way different in the later games
hold on hold on hold on got some more
secrets to discover here
wait really is that just a a dead hit
well there's got to be more to this room
guys oh there we go
now can i like shove him oh
wait that might be what you're supposed
to do with him
get out of here
wait did we just kill him no that's not
what i meant to do
it's okay he'll land on his shell i'm
probably probably in some water or
something he'll be fine guys don't worry
don't worry it'll be totally fine
okay let's head on up this way grab the
save game book
i i still want to know what's behind
that gate though i don't like that we
have no idea what's behind that gate
i hear and yet another chocolate frog
wait maybe this is going to take us to
there oh yeah it loops back around
taking us back into the room and there
should be a gate right here on my left
yes sir perfect come on
right there more birdie bop beans
we need to make up a little jingle like
every time we get a birdie about bean
zelda and eat when he grabs an item you
got all the little zelda tunes
cindy won you get you out of the way all
right are we almost done
i'm gonna grab this just to take me to
max health oh
well so much for that because apparently
the venomous tentacula had other ideas
so now i'm not gonna get the foil
sorry we're still pretty close is that a
secret passage
don't think so all right we're gonna
take our time incendial on each one
[Music]
i really should pay closer attention
like
to how many he said to bring back i just
gotta grab them all
everyone that you encounter on your way
that's gonna be three more bringing me
to 15
total 15 seems like a nice number
i want to say it's 20 though some reason
i'm thinking 20.
ah are we finally going to get max
health
is this it is this the moment yes there
we go and a single birdie bop bean
all right that was totally a guess
i mean i played this game years ago but
i was like wait a second there's got to
be something else going on here
there's got to be another way to cross
all right i thought we messed up
i thought we messed up
[Music]
all right wait for those to cool off
looks like it gives you three every time
okay three off of uh every
little plant here
all right we're up to 18 now so if i'm
right on 20
then we only need two more
jump for it harry
i'm really glad he grabbed on there you
guys any of you who watch part one you
know there was a
section where i thought he was going to
grab on and he didn't
and it remains the only time i've died
playing this game so far
okay now we're going to spin you flying
off
we've got some smaller rocks over there
yeah don't worry see we knocked him down
in the water he's he's totally fine you
guys
hagrid would not approve of us
permanently harming these creatures in
any way
don't worry guys don't worry
it's gonna be another secret right here
over to the right
yes
[Music]
oh wait maybe not i thought this is
gonna loop back around
where we saw that that gate
looks like this is just for the final
seeds right here
go ahead and grab this seed right there
okay that brings us to 21.
yeah i don't i don't know how to get in
there guys
[Music]
see is there a way right here
no alohomora oh okay
all right all right so that's gonna be i
guess
let's just go follow this arrow maybe
it'll still move back around maybe
there's a way that it will loop back
around
in all honesty as long as it's not a
wizard card i don't care anyway
they can keep their bodybot means
okay it's going to take us here now
we're going to go to the right
and yeah i guess that's it
back at hagrid's hut
now we're going to turn these into our
boy hagrid see if it helps to hatch
norbert
great work harry you've collected all
the fire seeds i need
excellent there's a wizard card oh and
he gave us a wizard
come on inside harry wipe your feet now
wipe your feet now sorry about that
is that slytherin i think that's
slytherin
trying to remember all this uh old
artwork because it is slightly different
than a lot of the
newer artwork
yes indeed salazar slytherin
medieval wizard dates unknown co-founder
of hogwarts
gave his name to one of the four
hogwarts houses
man if they made this game now and they
put in the wizard cards they'd have a
lot more that they could put on there
go ahead and put them in the fire harry
oh yes let's go let's go
[Music]
you've done it harry it's hot let's go
where's norbert yeah there he is
he's a norwegian rigged up you come me
beauty
thanks harvey here take this dude he
already looks
really big some creatures sleep take
this flute
oh you must get ready for quidditch i
wonder where we're gonna need that
i wonder where we're gonna need that
guys
all right well that seems like a great
spot to end this one guys
wait wait maybe not okay there we go all
right guys thank you so much for
watching
this episode harry potter and the
philosopher's stone make sure you tune
in for the next one if you haven't yet
subscribed don't forget to hit that
subscribe button before you go and
ring the bell as well so you'll be
notified anytime i post a new video
as always guys make sure you let me know
any feedback you have in the video how i
can make these better
thank you all so much for watching and
i'll talk to you again soon